c'est l'heure de la question qu la
question la question coquine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'hésite entre 2,6 en france
coughlin avoir déjà fait des galipettes
sous la couette
non pas du tout mais dans un trio
chausson should we avoué attendre et
comment veux-tu savoir si vous êtes
éliminé vous êtes éliminés pour le sud
de la semaine je remets en éliminer
d'aujourd'hui attention sérieux
allez à votre a dit benjamin castaldi va
pour sera bourse en 38 35 50 22 18 5 ans
et l'autre côté 25 bouffer des dessins
25 18 23 11 30 pour thierry beccaro
qu'il a déjà fait ici mais ils sont
riches elle ça m'emmerde déjà en michel
mathieu
ça peut faire des arts déjà donne gerald
p de quoi ça fait bah oui oui oui oui
vierge et au data des tomates subissent
au coi 3 oui quand j'étais plus jeune
ouais mais c'est qu'on est à 20 ans 25
avec qui ballerines camarades et un
camarade nom des mannequins bah quoi
oui c'est ouf ben moi je préfère avec
une fille kim pépito qu'un garçon qui me
plaisent ou matures oui alors oui mais
pas de filles ont faites ce que vous
voulez garder au poker garde castaldi
l'a fait oui mais non vous avez mal vu
[Applaudissements]
avec deux films qu'ils avaient aiguisé
guy c'était fréquent mais c'était
quelques années mais très bien mais on a
pensé à voir mais non ce que je peux
vous dire c'était c'était leur métier en
fait non non c'est non sebag kartalis et
souvent je l'avais à la bonne réponse
combien vous avoir fait des galipettes
sous la couette
non pas au duo mais dans un trio chaud
chaud chaud classe bon sens des français
c'est moi alors c'est moi et moi
j'estime que les questions kelly elle
jean michel maire vous perdez tous les
deux votre pote
[Applaudissements]
demain nous irons pas à la question
coquine et vous l'avez dit vous allez au
poste